wir bleiben vor Gericht mit einem
schrecklichen Verbrechen
Kinderpornografie das sind widerliche
Taten über eine Kinderporno Plattform im
Darknet dann Täter weltweit schlimmste
Fotos widerlichste Videos ausgetauscht
und verbreitet jetzt stehen vier
deutsche Männer vor Gericht sie sollen
verantwortlich sein für ein riesigen für
ein abscheulichen kinderpornoring
diese Männer sie haben unfassbares Leid
angerichtet sollen für einen
gigantischen kinderpornoring
verantwortlich sein Alexander g
Christian K und zwei weitere Komplizen
Alexander g 49 arbeitete als it-mann in
einem kirchlichen Kinderheim in
Oberbayern hier versteckte er einen
Server für seine abscheuliche
kinderporno-plattform gezeigt wurden
Fotos und Videos von schwerstem sexuelle
Missbrauch doch damit nicht genug um
seine Kranken Fantasien auszuleben
installierte er sogar Kameras im eigenen
Bad so konnte er seine Kinder Filmen im
letzten Jahr dann der Zugriff fahren da
kommen Alexander geh auf die Schliche
das BKA und die Staatsanwaltschaft
sprengen schließlich die Plattform im
Darknet es folgen Durchsuchungen und
Festnahmen in Deutschland und Paraguay
denn dort versteckt sich Christian K der
50-Jährige ist den Behörden bereits
bekannt wegen Exhibitionismus und
sexuelle Missbrauch von Kindern jetzt
müssen sich Alexander g Christian K zwei
weitere vor Gericht für ihre
abscheulichen Taten verantworten
[Musik]
unser Kollege Jörg völkerling begleitet
diesen Prozess Jörg wie kann die Fahnder
diesen Männern auf die Schliche
ja das diese vier Männer sich jetzt hier
im Sitzungssaal 9 des Landgerichts
Frankfurt verantworten können das war
erstmal der akribischen Arbeit von
verdeckten Ermittlern letztlich zu
verdanken seit 2020 durch eine
Gesetzesänderung konnten sie auch selber
aktiv werden in diesen Foren konnten
künstlich generierte Kinderpornografie
durch die niemand zum Opfer wurde als
als Vertrauensbeweis sozusagen selber
posten und nahmen dann die Fährte dieser
Männer auf wir haben sie heute morgen
gesehen vollkommen unscheinbare Typen
Familienväter wie Alexander g
rotgesichtig mit Bart der eine dick der
andere dünn die lassen die Vorwürfe
jetzt heute vollkommen unberührt hier
sich seit Stunden quasi vortragen und
dann ging es ganz klassisch über
IP-Adressen die rekonstruiert werden
konnten eine Telefonica Karte aus den
Niederlanden die von den Ermittlern
zurückverfolgt werden konnte zu Andreas
Giese seiner Mutter über Bitcoins die
Alexander g in einem an einem Automaten
bei Holzkirchen getauscht hat er hatte
aber den Fehler gemacht bei dem M der
Server wo diese ganzen widerlichen
Dateien gehostet waren supportanfragen
zu stellen diese Supportanfragen konnte
man auf seine IP-Adresse in einem
kleinen Dorf in Oberbayern
zurückverfolgen und so konnte man
letztlich über Jahre sozusagen einen
nach dem anderen aus diesem Kinder
porno-netzwerk dingfest machen die
Anklageschrift das hast du uns gesagt
die war so grausam so widerlich dass das
Publikum immer wieder verlassen musste
den Raum heute und du sagst jetzt gerade
diese vier Angeklagten die haben das
quasi regungslos gefühllos dahin
genommen bist du guter Dinge dass die
eine gerechte wenn man überhaupt sowas
sagen kann eine harte Strafe bekommen
zunächst mal muss hier diese
Anklageschrift verlesen werden 200
Seiten die Staatsanwältin hat sich dafür
sechs Stunden vorgenommen und immer
wieder muss weil es um monströs ist die
Öffentlichkeit den Saal verlassen weil
es natürlich nicht nur um virtuelle
Taten geht sondern es sind tatsächlich
kindermissbraucht worden Alexander g hat
sich an seinen eigenen Kindern
vergriffen laut Anklage und für ihn und
für Andreas g die beiden Haupttäter
steht tatsächlich auch eine
Sicherungsverwahrung im Raum
der Verteidiger Michael weiß aus
Augsburg von Alexander geh hofft dass es
nur eine vorbehaltliche
Sicherungsverwahrung wird aber ich fest
steht es wird eine ziemlich drakonische
Strafe werden schon aus
abschreckungsgründen die fahren da haben
immer noch damit zu tun weitere
Ermittlungsverfahren gegen die 400.000
Nutzer einzuleiten und bei verschiedenen
Plattformen Löschungsanträge für diese
Bilder zu stellen die auf ewig wohl im
Netz kursieren werden
vielen herzlichen Dank mit allen
Informationen zu diesen
kindermissbrauchsprozess bei dem wir uns
weiter auf dem laufenden halten wirst
danke
[Musik]